en la última presentación describimos
una situación donde tenías un montón de
prestatarios que necesitaban un billón
de dólares colectivamente porque hay
1000 de ellos así que cada uno
necesitaba un millón para comprar su
casa y tomaron el préstamo de una
entidad de cometido especial lo tomaron
de su corredor de hipoteca local el cual
después se la vendió a un banco que creó
esta entidad de cometido especial luego
ofrecieron públicamente esta entidad y
recaudaron el dinero de las personas que
compraron los respaldos de hipoteca pero
lo que ocurrió fue que los
inversionistas de las hipotecas
proporcionaron el dinero de esta entidad
para prestarlo a los prestatarios y no
solamente estas personas están
obteniendo este 10% al año digamos que
tú tienes uno de estos respaldos de
hipoteca pagaste mil dólares por ello
obteniendo el 10% al año pero um de
repente crees que se colapsará el
respaldo de hipoteca si quieres salirte
de la situación si le diste un préstamo
a alguien no habría salida tendrías que
vender ese préstamo a alguien más pero
si tienes un respaldo de hipoteca puedes
intercambiar este respaldo con alguien
más y ellos te podrían pagar
mil dólares quizás menos quizás más pero
había algún tipo de comercio en los
respaldos a lo que podrías llamar
equidad porque tengo este respaldo de
hipotecas y puedo venderla justo como se
puede vender una acción y como lo dije
antes este restado de hipoteca para
poder poner un valor sobre él debes
hacer algún tipo de análisis de lo que
tú crees que vale debes analizar su
valor debes ver cuál será el verdadero
el verdadero o el verdadero valor cuál
es la palabra interés real interés real
y también recordemos que un respaldo de
hipoteca es una garantía cuyo valor y
pagos de ingresos se derivan de iu con
garantía por un conjunto de activos
ahora puede haber otros inversionistas a
cabo ya voy a poner otro inversionista
lo voy a dibujar bueno ahorita que
encuentre la lapicera lo dibujo ok aquí
está la lapicera entonces tenemos aquí a
este inversionista y a él le encantaría
poder invertir en un respaldo de
hipotecas pero nuestro amigo aquí él
cree que que involucra mucho riesgo así
que le voy a poner un sombrero entonces
el dibujo aquí el sombrerito
llamémosle este muchachito pop entonces
bob el inversionista él quiere invertir
en algo en algo que implique menos
riesgo y supongamos que tenemos acá otro
inversionista que no sé por qué se pintó
así mi lápiz él está raro últimamente
pero bueno este es otro inversionista
con una cachucha y digamos que dice ay
esto es aburrido nueve diez por ciento
por favor yo quiero am yo quiero ver
retornos más grandes y bueno él aquí
llamémosle pongamos el nombre supongamos
que se llama milk y mickey no puede
invertir en este respaldo hipotecario
bueno porque a él no le conviene no está
no es lo que él quiere así que ahora
tomaremos este respaldo hipoteca y
vayamos un paso más adelante vayamos a
un derivado lo que es un derivado es una
es una más complicada forma de respaldo
lo que un derivado es tomar un tipo de
activo y lo partes en partes para
dividir el riesgo así es como creas un
activo derivado es un derivado del
activo original entonces bueno veamos
cómo podemos usar este conjunto de
préstamos y bueno de una manera
satisfacer a todas estas personas
satisfacer a
aquí el inversionista que también quiere
bueno un retorno mayor y bueno riesgo
mayor y también a mickey que quiere
riesgo mayor a cambio de retornos altos
entonces ahora en esta otra situación
aquí tenemos a los mismos prestatarios
que pidieron el préstamo de un billón
colectivamente porque hay 1000 de ellos
ya lo había dicho y también está aquí la
entidad de cometido especial pero aquí
en lugar de partida la entidad de
cometido especial en un millón de
maneras lo que haremos será partir lo
primero en tres a lo que llamaremos
tramos y lo que será un tramo bueno se
puede decir que es un una clase es una
clase los tramos del activo los
llamaremos de equidad subordinado y
prioritario el tramo prioritario es
donde si esta entidad fuera a perder
dinero ellos los del tramo prioritario
obtienen su dinero primero es el que
implica menos riesgo de todos los tramos
que tenemos y bueno el subordinado es el
que queda así como se ve en medio en
medio ellos tienen un poco más de riesgo
pero bueno también tienen un poco más de
ventaja sobre los otros tienen
riesgo que el tramo de equidad y los del
tramo de equidad ellos son los que
primero pierden dinero entonces bueno
digamos que los prestatarios digamos que
ellos empiezan a fallar en los pagos
entonces todo sale del tramo de equidad
y eso es lo que protege al tramo
prioritario y al tramo subordinado para
que no pierdan aquí lo que hicimos fue
del billón de dólares que necesitábamos
obtuvimos 400 millones del tramo
prioritario 300 millones del tramo
subordinado y 300 millones del tramo de
equidad los 400 millones del tramo
prioritario los tramos de mil títulos
prioritarios y las obligaciones de
deudas garantizadas son las que tenemos
justamente aquí y bueno ya con todo esto
digamos que habrían aquí 400.000 de
estas y cada una tendría un costo de mil
dólares mil dólares ok ahora nuevamente
creo que tengo una situación como la
pizza no está escribiendo bien como
antes lo que bueno digamos que
estos cuestan mil y sacamos 400.000 de
estas entonces sacamos 400 millones de
dólares y digamos que les damos un
retorno del 6% ajá entonces bueno
quizás tú digas ok el 6% no es no es
mucho y bueno tienes razón pero pero
para estos chicos es un riesgo bajo
porque para aquellos no obtuvieran el 6%
estos préstamos de un billón tendrían
que ir más abajo más allá de de 400
millones cada año habrá 100 millones en
pagos verdad bueno porque es el 10 por
ciento entonces de sus 100 millones el
6% de 400 millones es 24 millones en
pagos así que 24 millones en pagos irán
al tramo superior y similarmente 300 mil
activos en mil dólares por acción
entonces en el tramo subordinado que
también habrán mil dólares en el tramo
subordinado y digamos que ellos obtienen
el 7% en retornos así que bueno digamos
que el 7 por ciento está fijo entonces
200.000 acciones 7 por ciento ellos
tendrán lo que es 21 millones de los 100
millones cada año 24 millones irán con
ellos 21 millones con los del tramo
subordinado y lo que sobre bueno esto
irá con el tramo de equidad los 300
millones del tramo de equidad ellos
obtendrán 55 millones asumiendo que no
hay fallos no hay pre pagos y cosas por
el estilo entonces bueno ellos ahí bueno
no sé por qué mi lapicero no funciona
ellos obtienen 55 millones o en 300
millones eso es el 16.5 por ciento en
retorno y se lo que piensas dices wow
eso suena increíble porque no todo el
mundo quiere ser inversionista del tramo
de equidad chicas del vídeo no lo sé mi
lapicera no funciona no sé por qué no
funciona bueno entonces intentaré seguir
sin lapicera y dices bueno entonces no
porque no todos quieren invertir en el
tramo de equidad chica del vídeo y bueno
pero una pregunta qué pasa si vayamos al
escenario donde hablábamos de de ese 20%
de los prestatarios que ellos dicen
bueno sabes que yo no puedo seguir
pagando esta hipoteca te regreso las
llaves de las casas y de ese 20 por
ciento solamente obtienes tuvo el 50 por
ciento en retorno
así que por cada una de estas casas de
un millón solamente obtienes 500 mil
para venderla luego en lugar de obtener
100 millones por año solamente obtendrás
90 millones por año y hay mil aquí serán
la extraño no funciona y hay ahora
y mi computadora se se congeló así que
90 millones en lugar de 100 millones
luego también los tramos el superior
obtendrá 24 millones y el otro obtendrá
21 millones pero ahora el de equidad
solamente obtendrá lo que es 45 millones
45 millones y bueno
aún está sobre el promedio pero bueno
digamos que un montón de prestatarios
empiezan a fallar en sus deudas y en
lugar de obtener 90 millones por año
obtiene 50 millones por año y bueno aquí
le a ellos te siguen pagando lo que es
24 millones a estos de acá al tramo
subordinado 21 millones y todo lo que le
queda a este 5 millones para el tramo de
equidad y 5 millones en 300 millones
ahora es menos menos del 2% en retorno
entonces ellos tomaron un mayor riesgo y
si todos pagan claro obtienen el 16.5
por ciento pero luego si empieza a ver
muchos fallos en los pagos si digamos el
retorno que obtienen cada mes se va por
la mitad al tramo de equidad tocará todo
el golpe hasta llegar al 0%
ah bueno entonces tienen mayor riesgo
pero mayor recompensa mientras que a
estos otros tramos nadie los toca claro
que sí muchos empiezan a fallar en los
pagos entonces también a ellos les toca
un buen golpe esto es una forma de una
obligación de deudas garantizadas es un
respaldo de hipotecas para una
obligación de deudas garantizadas y de
hecho tú puedes hacer esto este tipo de
estructura con cualquier tipo de
obligación de deuda a que esté
respaldada claro por algún tipo de
activo y nosotros aquí hicimos esto para
hipotecas pero puedes hacer esto con un
montón de activos por ejemplo una deuda
una deuda corporativa ajá o créditos de
una compañía o lo que más se usa lo que
más se escucha en la televisión en los
noticieros radio periódicos etcétera son
estos respaldos por hipotecas de
obligación de deudas garantizadas